pinwheel the necromancer who stole the
power of a grave Lord a mother a child
and a father all fused into one form his
tale is one of guilt regret and a
desperate desire to fix his mistakes
death masks are mementos of the dead
representing the wearer before they
passed away masks of the father
this mask belonging to the valiant
father represents great burden and
equipment load the father made a mistake
and he carries that burden with him
it's literally a constant weight upon
him mask of the child this mask
belonging to the naive child represents
the limitless energy and stamina of
youth mask of the mother this mask
belonging to the kindly mother
represents the life giver and her
vitality a long time ago something
happened to this family and they were
brought together through necromancy the
father bears the weight of his wife and
his child on his back a family woven
together to become pinwheel it seems as
if in another time long past the human
mother and child died tragically and the
father was overcome by grief without
family it is said that man is alone in
the world but he was valiant and in his
desperation to be reunited with his
family he took great risk to steal power
from a lord of death nito with this
power he attempted necromancy reviving
the corpses of his wife and child but
something went wrong in his desperation
to be reunited with his family his
necromancy backfired and the family
became whole a mother child and father
reunited in a physical grotesque form
pinwheel in his current form pinwheel
resides in a crypt filled with his
tireless efforts at necromancy and
revival the creature is still sane and
continues to devote itself to
experimentation and research into
necromancy but why well the corpses of
the mother and child were restored but
at what cost they live on as an
abomination
the only thing pinwheel has managed to
do so far is split itself into various
forms which are dumped and discarded at
the entrance to nito's to assumedly
pinwheel is trying to split
self into separate beings so that the
father the mother and the child can be
properly restored as was originally
intended but nothing works
for some reason his Crypt is open when
you meet her imagine how shocked he must
be to see an intruder after all these
years someone who would interfere with
his attempt to make things right
who knows how close he was to success
how close he was to fixing his mistake